a world cup of traditional warmth and
Arab customs
with positive reviews from visitors the
hosts of the World Cup also got a chance
to present their values
atheists Hindus Christians have all been
visiting mosques for many a first
interaction with Islam
it is my first time in the mosque and I
learned a lot of things today by the way
in the beginning I was very scared
because
the history knew we are told when they
are praying they stand on the same line
the reason to show that everyone is
equal in front of Allah
hijab or a buyer it is a gift it's just
another Garb for women but versions of
it are banned in France and behind
protests in Iran in Qatar trying it on
is popular on social media religion is a
great part of the culture and to
understand people better is very
necessary to understand their religion
also for many people visiting the Middle
East for the first time or interacting
with Muslims the reality is different
from perceptions volunteers here have
been telling us that hundreds of people
have been asking them about Islam and
the culture of Qatar every day
for them the World Cup is an opportunity
to let people from all over the world
experience Islamic Traditions culture
and beliefs
dear Muslim leaders and organizations
routinely share concerns about rising
islamophobia and a negative portrayal of
Islam and this people-to-people contact
during a major sporting event will help
to allay misconceptions
there are thousands or tens of thousands
of non-muslims many westerners who are
giving shahada that what the Western
media is saying is garbage Qatar has
taken a very good stance of presenting
the country as well as the Arab
Community mainly the religion of Islam
that Islam religion of peace and its
religion for all the human beings not
only for the Arabs or not only for the
Muslims
the first World Cup in a Muslim country
has shades of religion in everything
from frustrating players after their
incredible wins the cheeks squeezing
kisses from mothers on the field
and the verses of Quran in the opening
ceremony
oh
all of it experienced by the hundreds of
thousands of visiting fans from all over
the world